There's this war that most people haven't
heard about. It's the war in Bosnia,
and it happened in like the early ‘90s. Big
thing that you learn when you study this war
is that there was a full blown genocide taking
place and the international community could have
stopped it. The U.N. was actually there trying
to kind of stop it, but they didn't. It's easy
to think that the U.N. is like this big like
global policeman, or like that it has some power,
but the U.N. is just composed of a bunch of
countries. U.N. soldiers are just soldiers
from other countries that the countries sent
to be a part of the U.N. In the early ’90s,
there weren't a lot of countries who wanted to
get involved in a conflict in Bosnia. So because
of this, the U.N. presence in Bosnia didn't
really affect much. It didn't stop terrible
things from happening. It's one of several
instances in the 1990s that the U.N. could
have stepped in and stop horrible things from
happening, but didn't. And we learned big lessons
from that. We made a whole video about this,
actually, and mapped the whole thing. And it's
just pretty wild to see how the world can fail
to stop something so horrible from happening.